[Musique]
en cette période de pandémie le festival
des rumeurs non fondées se poursuit au
québec rien pour calmer les angoisses de
la population
ce matin le gouvernement a pris la
décision à compter de lundi prochain de
fermer toutes les écoles cégeps
universités et services de garde
depuis le 13 mars les établissements
d'enseignement sont à l'arrêt au québec
c'est loin d'être facile évidemment pour
les élèves les étudiants les parents et
les enseignants
c'est dans ce contexte délicat que cette
publication a commencé à circuler autour
du 2 avril sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est une lettre avec le logo de la
commission scolaire des patriotes signé
par l'ex directrice de sept commissions
scolaires de la montérégie
on y affirme la fin de l'année scolaire
2019 2020 et qu'il est faux je cite ici
il est faux de prétendre que tous les
élèves passeront automatiquement au
cycle suivant fin de citation
ce qu'il faut c'est cette lettre forgées
de toutes pièces cette lettre n'a pas
été mise par notre organisation et tout
son contenu est totalement faux c'est ce
qu'a précisé la csp la commission
scolaire des patriotes par l'entremise
de son site web et de courriels envoyés
aux parents ainsi qu'à ses employés ce
n'est pas tout la lettre trompeuse
spécifie ensuite que tous les élèves
ayant une moyenne générale de 90 % et +
se verront assigner au cycle suivant et
pour les autres la lettre précise qu'ils
pourront se rabattre soit sur des cours
de rattrapage durant l'été ou sur la
reprise complète de l'année scolaire dès
septembre prochain
j'ai joint le ministère de l'éducation
et voici ce qu'on précise le statu quo
est maintenu
c'est à dire et je cite que l'année
scolaire 2019-2020 met pas en péril
même si la fermeture des établissements
devaient se prolonger
les enseignantes et enseignants elles
pourront exercer leur jugement
professionnel afin d'évaluer les
apprentissages de leurs élèves
fin de citation c'est ce que m'a précisé
l'attachée de presse du ministre qui
condamne vertement cette initiative
parce qu'elle contribue à désinformer la
population est susceptible de créer des
inquiétudes inutiles pour les parents et
les élèves
petit conseil pour tous les parents et
élèves d'ailleurs quand vous avez un
doute référez-vous
au site web de votre commission scolaire
et n'hésitez pas à consulter mon article
là dessus qu'ils se trouvent sur notre
page web continue à nous écrire salut
[Musique]